Okay, ladies and gents, this trade is going to be maybe a quick one, but I
actually wanted
to show you what discretion looks like.
Now, this should only be applied on really high probability reads and prices
where you
think like I discussed structural invalidation, but you think structure is
invalid in a certain
situation, depending on the day as well.
So you can see here, the M15 is actually bullish, right?
The M15 is actually bullish.
Big change of character in here, and so the M15 again technically is bullish,
but in my
redone price for this day's bearish.
And again, you can see here the yesterday where you wicked above these equal
highs in
the daily, closed back inside.
So what do you think we're going to expect?
We're expecting a selloff and price.
Now, we've already hit that low, but in my mind, I still think that we're going
to put
in a new low of day, especially for a London session, because London session is
opening
now.
So I'm expecting that London session will go and print a new low of day because
my directional
bias is already bearish.
Yes, we have already hit it, London could reverse, but I'm expecting that
London will
continue on that daily bias and put in a new low of day.
So this trade was taken based off of the idea that London will put in a new
love day.
And truth be told, this trade is actually more aligned with my other trading
model than
my SMC model, which is actually the main reason I took this trade, but it's
also a display
of how you could still use discretion, even for SMC, because there's a lot of
discretion
involved, but it's based off of contextual price understanding.
So you can see here that we are bullish, but I'm looking for shorts on this day
.
My bias was for shorts on this day.
Again, I have another model that allows me to take these trades from a data
perspective,
but that's what also allows you to execute discretion on SMC shorts, because I
'm expecting
that we have Asia low down here, massive point of liquidity, and it's the low
of day.
I'm expecting London to put in a new low of day.
That's what the thesis of the trade is about.
So internally, we're putting in lower lows.
You can see that quite clearly.
Again, we have an internal change character, but remember what I said about
invalidation
when it's Asia high and Asia low, we understand that how I'm looking at this is
like this.
Basically, Asia is for the most part invalid a lot of times.
We have a high in here that's basically Asia high.
Asia high gets liquidated.
That's already my time to go short.
Now you can see here internal M1 is what we're trading because the external,
the external
structure on the M1 is so large, it's pretty much the same as the M15 almost.
The M15 internal is the same as the M1 external, so M1 low and M1 high.
Of course, we're not going to wait for a break of this lower and then a test
and then
a trade lower.
Of course, no.
So I have a rule in place where when the M1 is visibly too large to make an
impact,
I will trade the internal M1 because all I want to do for the M1 is just it's
about
the now.
So it's less about the swing low and the X down on the rule and it's more about
understanding
what price is doing now.
And so you can see we have an internal higher high, internal high low, internal
high high.
And so I'm literally just waiting for the now to shift.
And you'll notice what is it again, it's the same as what we spoke before,
where you
have the run up, this little sell off manipulation distribution.
So we also have a distribution schematic.
Now we've shifted internal change of character.
So it shifted from internal higher high to internal lower low, internal change
of character.
That's my confirmation.
So now I'm looking at the now, the price action right now is bearish.
And I'm expecting the M15, sorry, the Euro dollar will put in a new lower day.
We have Asia lowers a target.
We have the expectation of a new low off day high probability and we have
internal M1 that
is in most cases would be the external M1, it's just the external M1 is too
large.
So everything for me is a green light on a trade like this, get in to the
market.
And so again, I'm looking at this, I can see we have here range distribution.
So this could potentially be the area.
But then when you put your stops in place, and you look at the target, the low
to one
to three is reward.
So for me again, to make the math make sense, one to three for me is like, I'm
not really
worth it.
Not get tagged into the trade, because again, I need a profitable ratio.
And so ultimately, I just need to make it at least a one to five risk reward,
like so.
And logically, we still have the unmitigated area of supply and the M5 of the
actual manipulation
up in here.
So this still hasn't been tested.
We still have a very small amount of inefficiency as well in this region.
So once a fire pressure award is kind of where price needs to be for me, for it
to ultimately
make sense.
And we're literally just playing on the idea that price will put in a new low
up day.
And if it tags it tags, if it doesn't, it doesn't, I'm not married to the idea
that
this trade has to tag me in.
If it tags it tag, if it doesn't, it doesn't, you don't have any times of set
trades that
just haven't tagged me in like it's, it's completely fine.
It's about when you don't get tagged in a trade, not then just chasing price.
In this instance, we actually get ended up getting, I'm going to call it lucky
because
it's not luck.
But we get fortunate in the sense that we obviously get tagged, price starts
going.
And eventually, we get the new low of day that we're expecting.
Now, what happens again, there's a lot of situations like this, prices aren't
falling
back.
People start getting scared.
It's not time to get scared.
All processed for price to pull back, and we end up getting wicked out one to
five risk
reward, which is, again, where are new price to be up?
And that's an instance where I've taken a position.
Notice that I'm not trying to swing for the fences on trades like that, but
that's the
example of where I'll take a position.
And you know, it's, we're technically bullish, but I've still shorted the
market.
Again, I do have a specific model for this, but also just by piecing the puzzle
together,
you can clearly understand.
Yeah.
So yeah, hopefully that also adds value because there are times where you need
to make decisions
as to whether you should look for long today because price is bullish.
If you become an advanced enough trader, you can start understanding and going
to plane
your own personal contextual discretion.